hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up
in the dock Greenpeace looks to
challenge the government in court over
its approval of new oil and gas projects
I'm going to tell you a bit more about
bird flu fears on the farm Islands
and nearly 400 000 more homes in Devon
and are subject to a hose pipe ban after
an exceptionally dry February
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis but first the high court could
decide today whether it will allow a
legal challenge against the government
to proceed over its decision to approve
new oil and gas licenses now Greenpeace
is bringing the action on climate
grounds arguing that any new oil and gas
exploration is incompatible with the
UK's emission reduction obligation we're
starting in Spain because it's gearing
up for a dangerous April heat wave as
temperatures look to set to exceed 40
degrees in the south of the country
smashing previous records now Seville
could exceed 36 degrees today over 10
degrees above the average for this time
of year now with temperatures expected
to be even higher tomorrow and on
Thursday it follows the driest March in
two decades
now the Scottish national party is
demanding that Westminster hands over
power for Energy emergency to the
Scottish Parliament arguing that the
revenues from the sector should be used
to benefit the Scottish people now the
party is Westminster spokesperson
Stephen Flynn made the case in a speech
earlier today where he argued that
Scotland was energy rich and should see
more of the benefits
now the offices of major American banks
have been targeted by climate activists
ahead of their annual General meetings
today Citigroup Bank of America and
Wells Fargo will hold eight GMS as they
face increasing pressure from
shareholders to end funding of new
fossil fuel projects HSBC announced in
December that it was an ending funding
for new fossil fuel projects and daxo
Bank also said it would stop financing
oil and gas projects earlier this year
nearly 400 000 households in Devon are
now subject to a hose pipe ban as lower
than average rainfall in February
compounds water shortages from 2022 a
ban was already in place for Cornwall
and parts of Devon but the extension
brings Plymouth Barnstable Tavistock and
Torquay under the same restrictions now
South West Water says the ban may be in
place until December and needed a break
the cycle of the drought
now bird flu is uh hitting at Britain
once again an important colonies of
course for wild birds after the National
Trust confirmed three cases on
northumberland's Farm islands and it
means the islands will be closed to
visitors again during the breeding
season after six thousand dead birds
were collected last year I'm joined Now
by The National Trust is Harriet Reed
and she's area Ranger for the
Northumberland coast and farm Islands oh
thanks for joining us Harriet so so we
know so far three confirmed cases so far
yes that's correct there's been three
confirmed cases on
um on the islands um one on the inner
group and two on the outer group
and what's the thinking about sort of
locking down just to to make sure that
you can kind of get a hold of this do we
think that this outbreak perhaps will
lead to another big problem for the
island again
we are hoping that if we restrict access
to the islands that it will limit the
disturbance to the birds
it is quite likely that we will see
similar
outcomes of the virus like on the birds
so we will see
um many
um dead birds again but hopefully we can
stem the spread this year
and just talk to us a little bit about
what happened on the island last year
because it was quite a big number there
six thousand dead
we were picking up a lot of carcasses
last year and a lot of the birds died
due to bird flu and
what happened was quite a few of our
dense colonies
um suffered so gillymots and Kitty wigs
which nest on the cliff areas
and just explain to our viewers how
important the islands are for wild bird
colonies
during the breeding season the islands
provide a place for many vulnerable
vulnerable species to breed and so it's
vital that we continue to protect the
islands and monitor the species so that
we can gauge how healthy they are and
also so that we can protect it for the
future and so that they will continue to
have this space
and it's impossible to to kind of stem
bird flu I suppose how confident are you
that you'll be able to make sure that
things are okay for the rest of the year
it's difficult to predict how both flu
will affect the island I believe
that if we do our best to restrict
access and try and intervene where we
can then we
stand the best chance
okay it will be the best chance for the
birds thanks Harriet that's Harriet Reed
from The National Trust there
um right well before we go just a quick
reminder that you can watch the climate
Show with Tom Heat this weekend that's
on Saturday and Sunday at three o'clock
and 7 30 in the evening
well that's all from us today thanks so
much for watching but do join us on the
daily climate show same time tomorrow at
3 30. bye for now